All right.
It's time for you to start applying
the layout skills you just learned.
And here's what it
looks like on desktop.
Not that great.
I think you can do a lot better.
For this part in the project, pick a set
of breakpoints that you think look good.
And then, use one of the patterns that
you just learned, to style the page, so
it looks great,
even on desktop and tablet.
If you didn't finish the exercise from
the last time you worked on the project.
Don't worry.
You can grab a working copy,
linked in the instructor notes below.
Make sure that you test on phones,
tablet's, and browser windows of all
different sizes, so that you get a sense
of what the page looks like everywhere.
Adjust your breakpoints, until you
get something that you're happy with.
And remember what might work on one
phone, might not work so well on others.
And of course, if you can, make sure
that you test on real devices as well,
because sometimes you'll
uncover unexpected behavior or
design elements that, well, you just
didn't expect, I'm going to show you
what we came up with but
this is by no means the right answer.
This is just what we like and you could
totally go in a different direction.
And if you're happy with it,
then that's great.
But this is what we did.
We've got a breakpoint here, and
then another breakpoint there.
The important part of this part of
the project is that you try out
different layout patterns,
and find out what you like.
Good luck.